[Musik]
hallo ihr nehmen heute gibt es einen 15
minuten nudelgericht und 20 angehaucht
und ich schreibe euch natürlich wie
immer alle ganz genaue mengenangaben und
den ligen
infobox ich schreibe euch unten rein wie
immer denn ich möchte direkt starren
muss machst du jetzt kommst du okay ich
mache süßsaure so sei mithin fast
doppelt so lange
das wird lecker du kommst später noch
für entlastet so ich starte jetzt durch
mit dem hähnchen das habe ich in
mundgerechte stücke geschnitten in
meiner fahne gebe ich jetzt kokosöl ihr
könnt euch entscheiden ich weiß es gibt
menschen die mögen den geschmack von
kokosöl nicht was ich gar nicht
verstehen kann aber dafür gibt es eine
lösung entweder nimmt ihr das normale
kokosöl das schmecken auch nach kokos
riecht auch danach oder in den main
dekoriert ist das ist dann geschmacks
und geruchsneutral
das werde ich heute auch nehmen und gibt
das sind meine fahne lasse schmelzen und
dann wird das hähnchen dazu gegeben
gesalzen und gepfeffert und nur ganz
kurz gebraten
[Musik]
so meine hähnchenbrust hat es wirklich
nur zwei minuten gebraucht nicht zu
lange an bahn sonst wird es trocken und
ich habe auch schon parallel meine bank
nudeln in salzwasser geworfen sie
brauchen ja auch nur neun minuten jetzt
nehme ich mir ingwer der das schälen das
klappt am besten mit einem löffel und
wert ingwer kleinschneiden chili nehme
ich mir dazu auch schön fein hacken und
dann kommt das noch mit zum hähnchen
[Musik]
irgendwann chili lasse ich jetzt nur
noch so eine halbe minute mit dünsten
und dann kommt sojasauce honig und ein
bisschen apfelessig mit dazu und jetzt
warten wir eigentlich nur noch auf die
nudeln also es wirklich ein
superschnelles gericht nur dann gebe ich
dann noch mit dazu wenn das alles und
dann ist auch schon fertig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das mädchen gegen uns so ein stück
hinter sowieso irgendwie verstehe ja
also wir machen jetzt den testlauf so
doch ich habe übrigens am ende noch
zusammen und steht nach oben drüber
gegeben sieht finde ich richtig gut aus
wie hast du gemacht hast was besteht aus
nur also wenigen zutaten honig und
sojasauce entwickelt sagt eigentlich
zehn minuten bokros ich habe am anfang
15 minuten gesagt wir bleiben der 15 ich
sagte dass wir bei kleinanzeigen wenn
ihr was umsonst verschenkt meldet sich
kein mensch aber wenn 25 euro kostet
dann melden sich die leute so ist es mit
diesem rezept zehn minuten riss denke
dass
der wird sich auf jeden fall nicht auf
sein amt verzichten wenn man darauf
weist das gibt den kick das selber so
ich liebe sie seien bei den dohlen
beschrieben also gut
dann auch richtig lecker ich denke die
schritte so einfach schnell also haben
sagt immer was zu sagen war echt ein
wunschlos glücklich ich bin happy ich
finde einfach 10 rezept also kann man
nicht nur sondern diese nötig diese
leichte schärfe und am ende juni habe
ich rein und wer ist einfach man kann
die ganze cd nämlich hat nur eine halbe
ich weiß
einfach wie möglich einen schritt weiter
aber ich finde das reicht noch noten
auch noch schön macht unbedingt nach
schreibt mir euer feedback rein wie es
findet denkmal alle waren begeistert
sein mandant noch einen wunderschönen
tag
typs mini platz ich muss immer so wie so
mancher krank
[Musik]
[Applaus]